all right stephen
yes stephen where'd you grow up where
are you from originally i'm in san diego
california san diego
and tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were a kid i
did
for a moment my dad's a vietnam vet
my mother got pregnant with me um
in 1970 i always had an older sister
that was she got pregnant with my mom's
from puerto rico
my dad was in the navy so he brought her
over she was 15.
um they made a home in san diego and um
i came in 70 and my other siblings came
i'm the only boy
so six of us all together and
my mom said my dad came back for his two
tours to do in vietnam
he was a different person you know
he does suffer from bipolar ptsd he's
he's on top of it now
he's sober now but
at that time when i was young one two
three years old i can't remember one or
two but
it's before i can remember vividly
he would pick any reason to beat my mom
down
i mean like how a man meets a man not
not just slap around and
push he'll whoop her
and it it traumatized me because i love
this man that's my father but at the
same time
i know the other boy in the house who's
supposed to protect
this man's beating my mom i hate him at
the same time so i was always torn
from from a young age you know
then you always expect me to step up and
be the man of the house and
do this be a man he's from louisiana
he's very old-fashioned
so you know i don't know if there's
anything to do with it but
you're very old-fashioned i mean when
i'm gone you're in charge of the house
you're the boy these are girls you take
care of them anything comes up
weird or strange it'll [ __ ] you up
that's exactly what he did
so i say bees for all kinds of reasons
so
you know very young too because i
thought that's how i was
i'm saying so i got accustomed to the
weapons i'm saying they got
i don't know like stranger than that
because my dad was all [ __ ] up in the
head man
he drank all day he worked he kept the
roof over her head but
vietnam twisted him man what i'm saying
he twisted him
even my mom said he's not the same
person like
whatever happened over there [ __ ] him
up you know
to the point where he he would love us
but at the same time abuse us and what i
couldn't stand
because between him and my mom my mom
puerto rico's very old-fashioned too
so she was like whatever goes between me
and your father
even he's damn near killing me that's
between me and here
you know what i'm saying so i just like
whatever when he starts going off to my
sisters
that's when it stopped
i think it was like 79 i was nine years
old my dad was i was watching battlestar
galactica i just love that show right
and my dad took my sister in the room
and that's what my sister screaming
and he used to drink heineken and for
some reason i grabbed the bottle
i went in the room and smacked him with
the bottle now the first time
i reflected violence with my father at
nine years old
my mom woke my ass at me with my ass
but i didn't care because
you know whatever you do to my mom
i don't accept it what do you do to me
i guess it is what it is but my sisters
though
never
what was he doing with your sister
he was real drunk remember he he's drunk
he's stupid
he's molesting systems
i asked my sister a couple times she
won't talk about it
and she made me promise i'd never be up
again but i wanted to know she was
she was doing her
that's when i was nine years old at
first i was american in my mind
i just want to kill this [ __ ] man but i
love you my father
but i want to kill you they start
messing with me
you're doing good now he's my dad he's
back in st louis right now
take care of my grandmother he's he's
sober now
born again christian part of the
freemasons and all that
[ __ ] whatever the hell i don't care but
i still remember that that man was he
drinking a lot or using
oh man when he came out of vietnam
my mom said he was all [ __ ] up i
remember he was at bongs all over the
house
he was in the 70s so we had bongs over
the house and
you know he's playing black sabbath
nodding off and
you know playing jimmy henderson nodding
off and i was like why
daddy i was going to sleep i didn't know
back again shooting dope and my mom's
always trying to hide it from me
but he was
he was my he was my father but i hated
him
but i loved him at the same time
but i think the only thing he ever
taught me
really
was to not trust nothing no one
and violence is a universal language
that everybody understands even animals
you can talk to your blue face to people
once you go upside their head
turn to a different thing then they get
some understanding or they don't and
just get beat the [ __ ] up
and that's what my dad used to do with
my mom my daddy my sisters
and i know he's doing more than that
because i remember he got at me one time
like you're a little [ __ ] you're not a
computer man you're a [ __ ]
you can't and he [ __ ] around he caught
himself spanking me
he did some weird [ __ ] man i was a
little kid i don't understand it
see my father but you don't put yo you
don't put your fingers in my ass [ __ ]
who's that
then i started thinking the [ __ ] you
doing my sister's man
that's why i'm gonna kill that man i
want him dead
i want to murder him
i'm going to stab him while i'm standing
stick my fingers ass too
[ __ ] like i'm saying but at the same
time it tore me because
he wasn't always a bad man literally
he's a little league coach and
we played little league he's in sports
and
i play pop warner played jv varsity he's
proud of that
as far as being a man
he never looked at me like man i don't
think to this day
he's different now he's born again he's
all that good stuff he's sober
he's all that he's he's a good man now
but he's slowly going crazy
too i can tell because the ghosts are
haunting him
and they haunt me too and i believe
and he gets mad at me somebody you know
you
you're you know you're a gang you're a
gang member now you you you're doing
this you're doing that you're doing
stuff you're supposed to be doing
you play jv varsity you could have went
to the pros you couldn't
you you guys could you know criticize me
but they're saying
i tell them you made me the [ __ ] i am
man
you may be this hateful violent person
you may you did this
i said watch you beat the [ __ ] of my mom
just because you come home from work
and the the the play wouldn't be warm
enough for hot enough you know what i'm
saying
that type of [ __ ] and don't get it wrong
my mom ain't no problem and this [ __ ]
me up too i remember one night
it's like about like 70 79 80 like
saying about you know back when um i
should love this show man from atlantis
man from madison it's blood actually
right it was coming on
but my dad's come on about six o'clock
so anytime from eight o'clock anymore
until six o'clock at night
it was happy time me mom my sisters go
to school come back have a treat snack
chill everything's cool but six o'clock
roll around
the dark cloud system because you know
dad's coming home
you know what i mean so
it's about time for him to come while
she's cooking but i noticed
he's drink heineken my mom took a bottle
from the 12 pack
put in the freezer hours before she
started dinner i'm like
why she do that for i was watching her
okay whatever i guess from my show i
knew how my dad was going to be coming
in
sure enough he came in tripping what did
the [ __ ] going on whoa [ __ ] you
sitting there
looking at that [ __ ] on tv what the
[ __ ] is this [ __ ] a fish man with
talking [ __ ] i'm just sitting up from
the army
but i noticed my mom looking at me with
these eyes like
don't even trip so
my dad she gave him dinner everything
went well he didn't smack her up this
night
thank god my sister's all in that room
i'm sitting watching my show because you
met from lannister and the hulk blue
frigate
on my show so he's talking [ __ ]
give me a beer says he gives him a beer
pops it
he drink it he finishes it he's talking
[ __ ]
he starts talking [ __ ] to my mom i
already noticed something to go
he's gonna get him smack her up
my mom says larry you want another beer
he said yeah give me another beer she
looked at me i looked at her
because i knew someone was going to go
down she went to the freezer where she
put that heineken
hours before it's stone frozen all the
way through
she grabs my neck like this instead of
grabbing like this didn't open it
walked the tune here's your beard larry
you smacked him right across the face
bust his old head wide open i was about
like not even
10 years old he had like nine
[Music]
my dad sent me on the lap because he
drove a
ranchero he sat on his lap says steer
i'm gonna push the gas just steer when i
tell you because he was all [ __ ] up
and my mom refused him to the hospital
and it [ __ ] me up because i'm like
i never see my mom get like that
but then i realized you know my dad
wolf's ass
this is respect and fear because i fear
my mom she showed me different side of
the day through violence
it made me fear her so basically
violence brings respect and fear
and i've grown up with my life with that
and
it's [ __ ] me all up and it's all
behind the abuse my father gave me and
my mom my sister
when he was in that zone but now he's
different
and i ain't gonna sad i don't applaud
him for it but
i can never forget i can never unsee
what he did to us man
and as an adult how has that
affected your life where'd you go after
you left home
the streets with homies you know
gang-banging them the homeboys and
getting into drugs and [ __ ] and [ __ ]
my people never wanted me to be part of
and violence violence that's what i'm
known for but everybody knows
my nickname my nickname is sb shady
blood they'd be like
is b gonna get weird he's violent
that dude he don't he might not know a
lot he's very educated he knows what
play football he tells you about some
things
but one thing he does know is violence
and
i don't like that man i don't like
violence i don't
like that because
it's an ugly thing man but sometimes man
like
my way of making sense
of it was this you don't understand me
and you
respect me if i have to beat you down
damn it to death to do it
just what my dad did does but it made me
hate him
so i expect people to hate me too
you didn't prison time yeah
yeah quite a bit what for why
robberies shootings great bodily injury
solar firearms so with weapons
um criminal threats terrorist threat
possession of weapons
stupid [ __ ] just
and i don't believe my father for making
me who i am because i had a choice
but i knew no better when i was a child
i didn't know and then that day he
he [ __ ] raped me because that's what
i
call it i don't give a [ __ ] was a full
sexual weird [ __ ]
he still gets figures in my ass man
call me a [ __ ]
he's my father i love you
but it's just sometimes i hate them
[ __ ] man you know he's different now
okay you're different now but you
then he acts like didn't this [ __ ] ever
happen
i mean never fought three different
occasions i mean fist fights
as a grown man like i'm not a boy now
when i was growing
just recently about not even five years
ago and we ain't talk since
but he asked my uncles my aunties and my
granny how how's he doing
how how steven know how stevie doing
i know it's not
is foreign blamed god
i get angry god like [ __ ] [ __ ] is
this
i asked for this man i'd ask for his
life man
i asked for another [ __ ] you guys kept
me unborn and
irrelevant but you gave me this life you
know
i'm supposed to find reason and
profoundness with it or find my calling
and all this [ __ ]
when is this [ __ ] to me it's like a
living [ __ ] hell man
to live with this [ __ ]
i'm very protective of women very
because
i said i see my dad's meeting my mom
he's a peter like he hate her man
i've i've hit one a couple times twice
my life i've made a female
and i hate myself for i just
i don't know man he [ __ ] me up man
that's my father i love him but
at the same time i [ __ ] hate that
[ __ ] man
you came in the room that thing told me
i'm a little girl i should be
like like with my sister to be a little
girl
and then i would have accepted the whoop
and i always stepped into beating
but he and he followed me man
and our drugs are part of your life now
no i just drink now i've
let drugs go on they're no good for me
i just drink i drink a lot
a lot and that was his hang up too
i went through the drug thing sean pcp
chris chris nasty went to the cocaine
put alcohol alcohol makes me numb
it makes me not
care but at the same time he's
angry and i'm angry drunk sometimes
right
you know if i'm wrong i like her i feel
some type of way
oh boy i mean i'm banned from clubs all
around pasadena [ __ ]
i can't even go near them you can come
in here
because last time i was there two people
went to the hospital shut the club up
and just crazy [ __ ] man
and i wonder where the [ __ ] [ __ ]
comes from
and my grandmother says it's rage
because you have rage
against the things that happened to you
as a child
[Music]
this is her son she talking about my
father
that's why i love my granny man she's
like she keeps it real
she was he was a torn [ __ ] up american
from vietnam
he was a young kid when he went to
vietnam when he enlisted
to the navy he was 18 years old he went
to vietnam when he's like 1920.
and he was a door gunner you know
door gunner that just go clear villages
remember one time i asked my father
right this is like
1999 91 i just got out of hawaii
because you that big bad gang banger
like drive-by shooter
how many people killed i was like man i
asked no [ __ ] like that
how many [ __ ] you don't kill and i've
seen his whole face just falling
and i know he did two tours in vietnam
he's a door gun all right
he said i don't even know i don't
[ __ ] know i'm about to kill
i think that's a big part of what [ __ ]
him up
because you know the military you know
raised me from san diego family from san
diego
back back south too but san diego my
grandfather's
cb in the navy my video to korea
he did a world war ii um my dad two
tours in vietnam i was supposed to go to
the navy
that didn't work out come to jail
young kid but
you inventory follow orders man i said
they [ __ ] my dad up man because he's
you know my little pictures of when he's
a kid like
he was a happy child man i could see me
in him
now he's all [ __ ] up don't get me
wrong he's living his life but it's like
a marionette like because i know
them ghosts and ghouls are still in
there
do you have kids yeah i have
quite a few kids got seven kids
did you raise them half-assed and out of
jail but
i was making sure they had everything i
wanted
but my daughter erica this is my third
oldest
she said the one thing i ever wanted
from you daddy is the one thing you ever
gave
what the [ __ ] you mean i gave you
everything you money clothes
you go you're the fly [ __ ] whatever you
need i give you what do you mean
because the one thing you never gave me
was you [ __ ] because you always
in jail
you know
they're doing well my kids are all good
i got one center prison
you know what i'm saying
that's just how to create crumble what
i'm saying he got [ __ ] up out there on
that meth and
he from armed 30s down this way
and the 30s here [ __ ] he got off that
meth one night got tripping and
barricaded himself
inside of a burger king on jefferson
crenshaw tripping
18 years for it but you know
that's my responsibility i'm saying but
my father man i love that man
but he [ __ ] me up because
he was [ __ ] up i think went to vietnam
it [ __ ] him up bad
and he just he volunteered for another
tour why would you do that
right but i guess he was young at the
time felt like hey [ __ ] it
my military is my duty right
he came out all [ __ ] up
and now he's just all [ __ ] up he has
to take all kinds of medication now
he's bipolar they originally diagnosed
him as not depressive
now it's bipolar what emotions do you
deal with
anger rage
compassion i care but i care too hard
i love hard i know when somebody i feel
they betrayed
my love turns into hate real quick but i
still love that person
but i said i hate you at the same time
it's weird i don't know how to explain
it
especially with the females in my life
man you know
i mean i got girls that love me or deaf
what i'm saying but i love them too but
you know women play games and then they
give them the
you know what i mean the media missing
the
the what's that called uh
the manipulation and i'm not the
smartest person in the world
but i am very very intelligent and i'm
very i know what the [ __ ] is going on
i see i call things the way i see them
and the way i see
this reality i don't deal with facades
in in
in fronts and playing along
nah i call like i see it so anybody that
knows me will tell you
i'm the most honest person in the world
i'll tell you exactly
how i see it if i see a girl playing you
and playing with you
and trying to just milk you and you come
to me you're my friend tell me hey what
do you think about this
hey the [ __ ] is milking you man [ __ ]
is playing for a fool man
but i love it i like not but you ain't
seeing it i'm seeing it and guess what
later in the game
same view you'd come back to me you were
right
because i know the game man i know life
people always have arterial motives some
more than others and some of your
mothers other people have
aren't negative you might want the best
for that for you
but most people i hate to say it like
this
this is the most plainest way i can say
it are maggots
they're maggots they're they they feed
on death
carrying and disease and they
revel in it it's like we said a minute
ago
they'll never admit that though all this
much drama i can't stand it
no but you revel in it and you have no
other way
and just be scandalous and scurvy and
slimy it's just your way
most people are like that but then you
got the ones on the side that are
a goal you know
i hope the thing i'm gold but
gold don't stink and i stink because
i'm tainted
you know what i'm saying
i'm not going to blame it on my father
because life said i did in my life
i abused my damn the only time i'm any
good for anybody's going on a
relationship
because i live for her i want everything
to be good for her
so whatever i got to maintain and do for
her
to make sure she's sheltered and
protected and good i'll do it for
by myself i wouldn't give a [ __ ]
i'm to the point now in my life and i
don't care whether they will die
i think dying me better because my
life's just been [ __ ]
[ __ ] man
it's their feelings dude
the [ __ ] i seen the [ __ ] i've went
through the [ __ ] my father did
my mother the [ __ ] he did to me
and god knows he did my sister's man
because he won't talk about it
and i see him getting older he's 68
years old he's
demanding he's gonna cry i'm telling
he's he's losing it man
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
the most important lesson i've learned
in my life
is that love don't love nobody man
but there is love there is
the righteous honorable thing to
to do as a man a woman as a person
period
integrity dignity it's a beautiful thing
but it's a it's going extinct
there's no more honor there's no more
that's why i see it i'm not saying i'm
right
it's the way i see it people are
we're regenerating we're not progressing
as a human race
we're regenerating back to to the
abominations we originally were anyway
degenerating you generate regress
whatever you know
i mean i know the bible i'm i grew up in
the church you know fam i know
i know the lord i don't believe in god i
know he's real
that's me there is a higher power
believe me that
but
like i said a minute ago we're
regressing
to generating back into the abominations
we remember anyway
so basically i hate to say it like this
i don't think there's no hope for us
period i don't think god loves us
i think he just allows us to exist to
suffer
and in the end put the flame out be done
with it
because it's just too much man
i hope that i'm wrong i pray i'm wrong
but my father
the [ __ ] he went through the way i'm
seeing him now it's like a love
and a hate because i hate to see him
degenerating
into this you know the depression and
playing the part
you know but i know he's [ __ ] up
the last time i talked to him we just
bust out crying for no reason
and then my grandma's gonna say oh it's
the medication man that's [ __ ]
it's the ghosts it's the the haunting
it's the
it's the he knows man because sometimes
we go there because i told my mom i said
you know what so you want to talk about
my mom
let's try the times you whipped your ass
man let's talk about that
so much times you just come home drunk
and you're in your in your [ __ ]
meatloaf wasn't
hot enough you used to beat her down
like that's when speaks beat
[ __ ]
you know larry holmes or something like
you know what i mean
it's all about that he don't want to
talk about that he's mad it was
you know roar for me i told you we had
three fights fist fights
and every time he's with me my dad can
fight for himself
any you know military he fight i'm good
too but
everything tell me whoop my ass he said
it's not gonna be another time we're
gonna fight
we're gonna do this ever again the next
time we do it
it's gonna be the end for both of us and
that's not just
all right but now
he's like the shell of a man he's a
shell now
and when i was younger i wish that for
him but now
all right stephen thank you so much for
sharing your story man michelle man
you've been through a lot
yeah but life is what it is man
and i always hold on to this my mom
she always tell me this well don't kill
you only makes you stronger
and maybe i appear stronger but
my heart is shattered
all right that's it thank you man thank
you okay
you